it's all about where does the body go
and when does it you know when does it
go so here
hey here
i'm underneath now so i i can't come on
top in other words i'm going back to go
forwards but
this so from here from here
this morning i was saying about get the
fingers in on the ken and then power up
the wrist if those remember
then power up the wrist
what most of you are doing is you're
doing this you're then turning getting
in here now trying to power up and
that's strength against strength
what you need is the thing that you
don't know is how much you might know
how much you weigh on the weighing
scales but you won't know how much you
weigh
now
in math so you've got to rely on that
being
you've got to rely on that being
the thing that
that's going to lift him right so will
you spiral
all right
and then you throw
if we all agree to uh
we don't normally say this in iwama
training but if we all agree that uki's
going to follow
and you come back to this one and you
come here and you come
under
throw them down
[Music]
i'm saying and go along with it for a
bit
so that you can find out what pattern
you're supposed to be making
[Music]
here is what you've been doing instead
of throwing
press this down
go under
as close as you can to him here his
hands always gotta be in front of your
head
and then
it goes down
[Music]
i've even seen cytosensei struggle with
this
so
he said he said he watched those senses
struggle a lot of times so don't think
that because we're human beings we're
going to get it perfect if you make too
big a
arc i've now moved him away from me
so now when i go here see his hands are
vanishing behind my head
and i won't get a good what i call sheer
naggy
i have to mold
like a gel
into a space that isn't as big
as i am
so i've got to get my head around i have
to somehow
go into a space that isn't as big as me
what sounds stupid doesn't it but that's
how i have to think
so here i drop this down
i come here now this space isn't big
enough but i'm gonna watch my backside
[Music]
and then
there's space for my head to come out at
the end
and what we do is we don't move our butt
out the way
quick enough and we come here and we try
and now turn it and we get caught up
about here
and that's where it's difficult
so you're going to have to shift
this
see this head's still here
okay very difficult one but enjoyable if
you get it come on